here for reaction fox news legal analyst
greg jarrett along with former florida
attorney general pam bondi
both of you thanks so much for being
here tonight greg let me start with you
you got a great piece up at foxnews.com
talking about the constitutional hurdles
of this oh that pesky document that they
wish they could circumvent
yet again it might be the one thing
standing between us and a gun grab
yeah i mean look it's understandable
that emotions are running high and
emotions sometimes lead to action but
those actions aren't always lawful and
joe biden can demonize the nra gun
manufacturers and republicans only want
that's not his problem the problem is
that
pesky document called the constitution
and specifically the second amendment
you know the landmark heller decision
the united states supreme court
validated the individual right to keep
and bear arms they said some limited
regulations are permissible then they
name them keeping guns out of the hands
of felons in the mentally ill away from
schools and government buildings but
it's abundantly clear that beyond that
doing what biden wants to do which is to
ban an entire class of weapons owned by
15 million americans
would not pass constitutional scrutiny
in fact the liberal-leaning ninth
circuit just last month
uh struck down california's ban
involving the sale of
ar-15s biden knows all of this because
in his speech not once but twice last
night he said if we can't ban
assault weapons then and he proposed
some fairly reasonable
other options such as increased school
security red flag laws better background
checks and so forth and there's actually
some bipartisan support for that but
what he's asking lawmakers to do
appears to be unconstitutional
unless
you amend the constitution but that
requires a vote of two-thirds of both
houses ratification by three-quarters of
the state that ain't gonna happen
that'll get happen pam and you know
every time he talks about it he
demonizes uh he always goes after the
straw man of the nra right that's the
one that he loves to talk about but even
doing that is condescending to average
americans who simply understand uh the
the the centrality of the first and
second amendment the individual rights
given to empower individual free people
uh
they've totally lost sight of that uh
and and they would go forever i mean i
really mean this they'd go for every gun
if they could
they would pete and as greg that piece
was incredible that you that you put in
fox news today i think everyone should
go on and read it because it lays out
exactly what you just said um it's it's
a fundamental right it is our right to
bear arms and to defend ourselves and
you know it's interesting the joe biden
of the 80s who we seem to like a lot
more who said that yeah you're not going
to take guns out of the hands of
criminals was absolutely correct you
know pete when i was a young prosecutor
way before i was attorney general i was
in my early 20s i had a stalker
for years i don't talk about it a lot
but i learned to shoot from law
enforcement they taught me to shoot
because i didn't have the luxuries that
hillary clinton has that joe biden has a
full-time protection and i had to learn
to shoot a gun to protect myself my
stalker ultimately committed suicide
that's how serious it was but i deserve
the right to protect myself as do all
americans in their homes to be safe and
that's what the second amendment says
and that's what heller says loud and
clear the heller opinion from 2008. and
i find it astonishing that they keep our
borders wide open and they let criminals
come into this country they let cartels
in they let gangs in and illegal guns
are coming into our country that way and
it's okay for that to happen but not for
law abiding citizens to have guns
craig it's just like speech even with
red flag laws the idea that someone else
gets to make a determining determination
in someone you don't know unaccountable
to you to make the designation about
whether the speech you're saying is
acceptable or whether the gun you'd like
to own is one you can own we're all for
you know the reality there are people
that shouldn't own some but it all comes
down to who the decider is greg
yeah you're absolutely right which is
why
many of those cases there's more than a
dozen red flag laws in states already
and they're being legally challenged and
we'll have to see how that litigation uh
goes forward uh you know the
there are problems with
several of the ideas he proposed last
night but the strongest proposal he had
more money for school security to make
sure that where our children are located
for seven eight nine hours a day that
they are safe and secure those are the
best measures and i do agree that added
money for health care programs would
also be helpful because that's a common
denominator that we see in so many of
these mass shootings
for sure pam we all only got about 15
seconds last word
yeah that's what we did after the
parkland shooting did everything we
could in florida to strengthen our
schools harden our schools and give more
law enforcement security at each and
every school in our state and we do need
to do that throughout our country to
protect our children
if you actually want to address the
problem at hand you're precisely right
pam bondi thank you for sharing that
that personal story and greg as well for
that great piece check it out at fox
news dot com hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else